coming up next week discussions focused
on the Brussels attacks radicalization
web accessibility and a mini plenary
welcome to the agenda kicking things off
a mini plenary will be held in brussels
on wednesday in thursday and they're
taking center stage at the fourth way
package and the implementation of the
eu-turkey agreements also on a two-day
plenary agenda protection of children
gender equality the discharge of the EU
2014 budget and calls to make attacks on
schools and hospitals a violation of
human rights in the aftermath of the
attacks in Brussels the spotlight fell
on belches fragmented society but how
the attacks divided on view people with
a greater sense of solidarity last
Sunday at a rally titled a marched
against terror and hatred thousands took
to the streets in a march of solidarity
in Brussels at the Parliament on Tuesday
a discussion looks at ways to prevent
radicalization invited guests include
interfaith groups representatives from
the think tank European Muslim network
ed was saying the author of Islamist and
a mother whose child went to Syria watch
out for the debate on Tuesday it is very
useful for us also to Belgian ministers
at this center of the fight against
terrorism come to the Parliament the
interior minister Yannis are born along
with it Belgian justice minister Kuhn
gains will join MMPs and debate on the
terror attacks and a civil liberties
committee on Monday and I officer news
in brief having farmed out refugee
management of turkey plans are now
underway to have an eu-wide safe country
of origin list refugees could then be
sent back to their country if it's
deemed not dangerous the first debate on
the drop report is on Thursday Tuesday
sees a vote to back an EU commission
report calling from countries to share
information on multinationals with a
revenue of 750 million euros continuing
efforts to protect the environment a
vote on a proposal to put a cap on
emissions for non road vehicles takes
place on Tuesday
and finally figure suggests that 167
million citizens still have problems
accessing public website to do basic
things such as filling in their tax
returns so how to make websites more
user-friendly and especially for those
who are disabled or elderly a trial of
between negotiated from the Parliament
and member states takes place late on
Tuesday and that's all we have this
gender take care and enjoy the week